my wife
liza is here in studio little applause
please
you sound like little you sound like
little church mice
uh and liza's here because she's been
working on a project that i love this
project and people say well you're
biased but i'm being make it clear i am
not a fan of my wife oh okay yeah we
just we are we don't i know everyone
else is everyone i know
you're only the only what your favorite
my favorite thing about you is liza yes
there you go yes yeah yeah um and that's
the sentiment that i get from most
people is they say
um you're annoying but we love your wife
i'm like okay um and i'm fills you with
rage fills me with rage because it's my
parents that are saying it
but
uh but i am thrilled because uh liza
welcome first of all to our little
studio thanks yeah nice to be here it's
nice to have you not at all weird yeah
i just love that we're not we can't
shout at each other
uh because you know there's there's
company here give us a minute
give us eight seconds
um i think we should leave yeah
uh
no you um liza you're here today because
you've been working on something that i
really love and i'm excited about it and
very proud
as your goofy partner in life that you
have made this really cool podcast that
we're going to share with people called
significant others that's right yep i'm
so afraid to make a mistake
why got this buddy what's that you got
this well because you know later on i
might hear about it uh
likewise yeah exactly
absolute best behavior yeah i know um so
fun
i promise you use your i statements
always say i feel don't accuse anybody
of anything hug a pillow if you need to
there's water
[Laughter]
well i think
that uh you've made this very cool
nonfiction podcast my favorite podcasts
often are that i listen to
because i don't listen to this one
[Laughter]
not a fan of mine but
i love any podcast where i can learn
something
whether it's history or literature
and you came up with a very cool idea
which i will throw to you so you can
explain what significance others is all
about basically is about sort of um
looking at people who are just outside
the spotlight of history essentially so
um i've always been really interested uh
even before i was married to uh conan
about what it was like for people who
are married to you know the people we
read about in history books so what was
it really like to
date and be married to
uh president lincoln for example um
that's sort of the genesis of it and as
i started collecting more and more of
them and asking people is this anything
that anyone else would be interested in
besides me
conan was one of the first people to say
absolutely i would absolutely listen to
that which was i mean if you hadn't done
that i don't know if i would have
you know pursued any of this so either
thank you or it's your it's my fault
it's my fault
it's your fault um you cover all these
great people uh and things that i didn't
know because
i knew about obviously i think i knew
somewhat about gandhi i certainly knew
about lincoln um i thought i knew
about virginia woolf and then you find
out about these other people in their
lives that were
pivotal not always for good
which is fascinating this is not the
story every time of someone
uh who is um
saving the day in any way a secret hero
it's both they they help
and they don't help
and they influence the whole game as
everyone does no no one is an island so
i've been listening to them i think i've
listened to all of them except i think
there are a couple that i haven't
burdened you with but um no you've been
my first uh reader of the script often
and first listener to the scratch tracks
and
um you're a very good editor i would say
that that's nice i know i know this is
like sober you guys are like this is
also so similar
i want to know about the bad stuff is
there a murder
oh in the in the podcast yeah oh i
thought you meant in our lives oh is
there more
i feel very entitled when it comes to
like cleaning up the kitchen i've gotten
a little better you're you're much
better much better than i used to be but
it is i used to say well i'm done
and now let others handle things was my
declaration at the end of every meal now
the now the dishes end up near the
dishwasher
still not in it they're moving clothes
not in it but near it they're moving
closer okay they're moving so much
closer progress
you talk about the tolstoys gandhi uh
you mary lincoln uh nabokov's wife vera
maya angelou and james baldwin who i
didn't even realize had this incredible
connection
molly d thatcher and elia kazan virginia
woolf dr spock i mean gandhi is someone
who i i mean i just i don't even think
of gandhi as being in a relationship
because he's been he's become such this
holy revered figure that he's almost you
know beyond that godlike and the gandhi
one was the one of the
uh one of the only ones that i didn't
have in my head before we started it was
actually a suggestion of nick liao who's
a team coco person
and i'm so grateful for that suggestion
because like you
i was like he had a wife
there's a national holiday named for her
in india um which my friend who voices
uh kasturba and then also talks to me
afterwards about it um
you know grew up knowing basically that
was all she knew so that's interesting
too that like you can even be from the
culture and know of the person and still
not know anything more and she was
massively important in his life so
there's a lot of
my favorite thing
like yours is that it's um not all good
or all bad that these are really
complicated people and complicated
relationships and
in this era of sort of re-examining
historical heroes
um i sort of love that when the
re-examination can be
incredibly complex and nuanced and that
it's not just hey guess what this guy
was secretly an [ __ ]
guess what
a lot of them a lot more and it wasn't a
secret publicly an [ __ ] right exactly
and i think that's where i've got
everyone fooled uh i i you mentioned
that you had someone a friend voice
you've got a lot of people yes uh
voicing things uh nick offerman is leo
tolstoy megan mullally sophia tolstoy
tim oliphant
uh rita wilson jamila jamil darcy cardin
lisa kudrow paul f tompkins i mean it's
uh we're very lucky yeah i called in
every possible chit that i could i don't
think anyone's ever going to take our
call again so
you're welcome
yeah well yes including matt gordon oh
that's right what what part did you play
i play a reporter in the lincoln episode
when you're describing in great detail
mary lincoln's
uh the shape of her head yeah it's a
really really misogynistic
sort of slam of lincoln or mary lincoln
yeah yeah it's crazy and we naturally
thought of you yeah you were perfect i
love that they brought you in
eliza brought you in to be the creep
yeah lincoln episode yeah i do play a
lot of creeps
i'll edit that out what was uh was there
one thing that you learned that just
really shocked you
other than that gandhi had a wife yeah
that would take well that was that was
surprise number one i mean there are a
lot of really fascinating moments i i
don't really want to spoil anything um
but and and one of them and you didn't
know lincoln was shot it's true guys i
really learned how to did you know he
went to a theater so hey spoiler man
yeah exactly um yeah i don't wanna i
mean noth everything was you know
surprising at a certain point i think
the dr spock episode might be the most
surprising to me
a lot of your fans might not even know
who he was because he's so excited about
that because i was raised on that board
yeah yeah and it's a real generational
divide like i bet you could you know
find the exact number above and under
where people do or don't know about him
but um it was a big oh dr spock was the
uh child
care guru yeah not the vulcan yeah
his book yeah and it was um i think in
the it was 50s 60s
in 1946 same year my mother was born wow
and it
revolutionized there's a great quote um
by a guy
who wrote a profile on esquire in like
86 when spock died in 98 so it was like
toward the end of his life but not all
the way at the end and he was like
this
this had such a profound influence in
such a quiet way because it was these
articles that he was writing in women's
magazines that were lying around you
know hair salons and
nothing else has affected so quickly and
so vastly
how the world regards babies and handles
them and raises kids and you know so
there's all this stuff about like he
created the hippies he was the
responsible for the me generation
there's been a lot of backlash the
feminists hated him for a while and then
he changed some stuff and got back in
their good graces and
meanwhile you know his own family was
kind of a disaster yeah but whenever
someone writes a
here is how to parent your child you're
asking for trouble yeah within 10
minutes and he just could start killing
people and who wasn't like
he wasn't a big um like he didn't have
the kind of ego that a lot of experts
have he was very ready to revise what he
had written and to collaborate and
he didn't want to own it and be right
all the time but
then there's this just point where he
couldn't take his own advice you know
like there's just you can't
fix
what gets put in the hard drive kind of
so anyway it's it that one to me is
really fascinating he's playing dr spock
un
cast as of now just to be intentionally
confusing
well he's passed on
it was just funny to me if we got
zachary quinto
who plays
spock now
and got him to play dr spock but but
then do a lot of disclaimers up front
zachary quinto will be playing dr spock
it's not that dog we know he plays him
just un i love unnecessarily confusion
i'm going to ruin your podcast no and so
his his son one of his sons said that
when dr spock from star trek became a
thing he was so relieved because
suddenly there was another
when people would see his last name and
they would say are you related to dr
spock you know and he would
ugh i don't wanna because he's then the
living test of his dad's you know work
and so
when they would say are you related to
that's why you can he'd be like yes
exactly that's what i'm related to
that's that's why i root for conan gray
you know
i just want him as to our children yeah
exactly i'm tired of being that conan so
it's root so root for conan gray yeah of
course yeah because i can't take the
burden anymore too much yeah i feel that
same way about the matt gourley that's a
contractor in northern california you
know i can't get uh out of his shadow
well he's just a really good contractor
he's because he's gonna be playing dr
spock yeah yeah
uh okay let me make sure i get the word
out significant others is available
right now it's uh it's already out a new
episode of significant others drops
every wednesday with bonus episodes the
following day
so be sure to subscribe wherever you get
your podcast